Hello everybody, this is section 11 of Beating Credit Climb.
This section I'm going to be talking about the RIFE machine.
Now this presentation that I'm going to do here is actually taken off of another presentation
that you can find on our website.
So these slides look a little bit different as we go through them so you can see they're
a little bit different.
But I'm going to cruise right through them.
I'm not going to read the slides and bore you and I'm not going to go through the exact same
presentation that you can find on our website.
And I do want you to know that we use a RIFE in our office with all our patients that
come to us with cancer or autoimmune line.
In fact, you cannot be treated without using a RIFE because I think it is a huge important
piece.
Now understand, it's a tool.
Like any tool, you can buy an electric screw gun and if you don't hold it correctly and
charge it up, but use it correctly, it's not going to do you any good, same thing with
a RIFE machine.
I am also aware that there are numerous RIFE machines on the market that claim to be as
close to the way Royal Raymond RIFE made it as possible.
However, I have used many of them and I have still many of them in my possession and I use
only one with patients right now that they go home with and use on a regular basis.
They'll talk about that in a few minutes.
So my bottom line is, I just want to know what works.
Now go on our website and you'll see this presentation about RIFE.
He won numerous awards.
His biggest award was with his production of a microscope that he could see germs, he
could see viruses in his microscope.
What of his philosophies was that he believed he found what major cause of cancer, which was
a cancer virus?
Well, this is said to be found out to be true that a cancer can be caused by a cancer
virus.
Matter of fact, they've created them in laboratories to try to use them as germ warfare, but that's
another story.
And he won numerous awards.
He was actually used by the University of Southern California School of Medicine sent all their
terminal cancer patients to him because of the other machine that he created, which was
a RIFE machine, which we know was a RIFE machine today.
But it was a frequency generator, it used light frequency.
So it created photons through light frequency, it was able to, with an analog scale, dialing
the specific frequencies that RIFE thought would work to kill cancer cells, and that's
what really gained him notoriety.
And that's why the University of Southern California sent him his cancer patients.
The his frequency generator machine was basically noticed by multiple hospitals.
Unfortunately, this was right at a time when the AMA was taken over by the pharmaceutical
industry.
And anybody that was not using pharmaceuticals to treat cancer was basically put out of business.
That's very unfortunate.
Here's an award ceremony that was in RIFE's honor at the time for all the work that he
did and the success that he was having.
Unfortunately, he died and broke in man.
At the time when the AMA went through and basically shut down all the cancer clinics that were
not using pharmaceuticals, many of those cancer clinics moved to Mexico.
That's where we have the Mexico clinic cancer clinics today.
Mexico, Mexico, Mexico, Mexico, Mexico, and they're the ones that developed the Mexico cancer
clinics.
No.
Unfortunately, you go to the Gerson clinic in Mexico, all you get is Gerson.
You go to the Hoxy clinic, all you get is Hoxy.
I have a problem with that because not everybody fits into that round hole.
Well RIFE, ironically, was the closest to Mexico.
He was from San Diego, but when his place got shut down and his microscope was destroyed
by the powers that beat at the time he just gave up the ghost.
He's just done with the fight.
He lived his whole life and he saw his work discredited.
He just gave up and he died and broke in man, very, very sad day.
His work was lost for years and until recently, just the last 30 years maybe, it was picked
up again and used.
Unfortunately, anybody desired to truly help people that is willing to go against the medical
pharmaceutical establishment is going to be criticized, ripped apart, torn apart, shot
down, targeted, and every attempt made to shut them up, that is happening in our life.
So that is why we practice under the Pestoral Medical Association and we always ask for
people's prayer because we believe the only way that we're open, our doors are open to
be able to treat cancer in line of patients is because God keeps them open.
So we ask that you just keep praying for us for our protection.
RIFE is used today, it's basically frequency medicine.
It's in every major cancer book, labels, RIFE, I talk about it a lot in my cancer book.
But this is the RIFE machine that we use.
So we use the true RIFE, this is a prayer that's a little bit, this is, we use a little updated
version, I could find a picture of the newest version, but this is the F-117, person uses
this by their bedside at night, that picture in the middle is the only picture I could find
a little child sleeping with what's called the hammer tube, picture on the far left side
is somebody standing on it, it's called a hammer tube because you could literally hit it
with the hammer and it's not going to break because the bulb is inside of a plastic tube.
So it keeps it protected, it's meant to sleep with, it can stay, sit on a stand like by that
picture with the lamp, but we have people typically just cuddle with it, our cancer patients
cuddle with it as close to the source of cancer as possible, though the light will go out
about six to eight feet, so you can put it between a couple of people to get the results,
the closer it is to you, the better results you're going to have.
Comes with a computer and a program that we program specifically to that person, the biggest
mistake that you could make with a RIFE machine with Lyme diseases, you could use too many
kill programs that you could hurt the person quite badly with it, so you got to be very careful
with it, so the program is really touchy with a Lyme patient.
Alright, hope you learned something, and I'll see you at the next section, and again this
presentation on the RIFE goes into it a much more detailed other website if you want to
look at it there.
If you have any questions, give us a call.